hello and welcome to New World review
your source for everything from now on
just everything everything review maybe
we'll see hi it's me again brand line
waifu here for episode 4 and more of
Hunter hunter I hope you're enjoying my
stupid rhymes because honestly it gives
me a sense of happiness rivaled only by
karapa chem I hope you're enjoying my
stupid rhymes because honestly it gives
me a sense of happiness rivaled only by
carajás sense of duty which reminds me
if you're enjoying this please let me
know I love the comments I'm seeing
though because I'm actively trying not
to spoil myself I'm leaving it to Liam
to tell me if people are enjoying these
if you are enjoying please feel free to
like and subscribe similarly if you're
not enjoying please hit the dislike
button because I can look at numbers
myself without getting spoiled episode 4
let's get right into it kazoo who needs
more intro than that right Oh mmm
spoilers there will be spoilers but I
mean we've had three of these now so we
know there are gonna be spoilers right
yes good ok let's move on episode 4
first things first
no actually no the audio is not a
teenager good I'm glad we got that out
of the way next crappy car has magical
eyes no I'm sorry we need to go back to
lay audio he's a teenager
I appreciate the people of my generation
and the next cuz I'm old or so I'm told
by my husband have been raised on young
people rescuing the world from the awful
things that are killing us and I'm all
for young people rescuing us but lay
audio a jaded medically trained
emotionally vulnerable but hiding it
teenager I have met many a teenager once
upon a time I was in fact myself a
teenager how can he be so jaded already
how did he get such a strong grip on the
medical system at such a young age why
why does he have a briefcase as a
teenager I mean I've always kind of
wanted a briefcase but if they were
going to spring the idea that he was a
teenager on us they could have left it
longer and maybe drawn out the age
related references a bit more I was
surprised when I found out his age but I
would have been more surprised if his
entire backstory were dribbled a little
bit more and that's something that I'd
say about the entire series so far all
of four episodes in it's beginning to
get dark now and I love that but I would
really appreciate having information
dripped out a little bit
I'm more Hansel and grettel than
Goldilocks when it comes to story by
which I mean I really appreciate finding
out information in slow steps drawn from
the evil witch unawares then I am a too
hot to cold just right person the amount
of information we've been given in the
first four episodes is a bit too much
too quickly it smells of quick we want
to do other things and these other
things will be more important more
interesting to us so we want it done I
can appreciate the excitement to tell
the story and I think I'm going to need
to read the manga once I finished the
anime to see how faithful this is to the
method of storytelling here but dumping
a lot of character background on an
audience is to me poor storytelling the
world again seems bland and for all my
husband's amusement at my character bias
this is a very character-driven anime
the colour is in the characters the
world is just a backdrop for their
neuroses my unfortunate sense at this
juncture however is that having thrown
out a lot of backstory in chunks we're
gonna have a lot more backstory thrown
at us but from the characters we've been
introduced to my concern is that we're
going to have a revolving door of less
important characters who all have
equally dark and dangerous backstories
it's entirely possible I'll be wrong and
I hope I am because that would get not
just heavy but boring very quickly
especially if nothing is resolved doll
see back to our backstory sessions and I
was very aware in a way that I haven't
been before in Hunter hunter of the
music and the effect it had on me during
their story descriptions I'm a very
emotional person and when I start to
hear certain chord changes in music my
emotions get drawn into what I'm hearing
the music sitting behind carpetas story
was romantic romantic with a capital R
which for those without a literature
background suggests idealism or at least
that's how it read to me the flowery
beauty of his people's eyes and his
description of how his people stared at
him from the pits of empty sockets just
her second I saw the stoic perfectionism
drop away in favor of the nom Haro of a
character who should be showing more
emotion than he is
by comparison the audio soundtrack and
art flashback were much earthier with
the buzzing of cicadas the simplicity of
the sound design putting us much more in
the moment with li Oreo than we sunk
into karappa cos experienced the
contrast as well as focuses in those two
moments
is startling we had karappa cos
obsession with the money involved that
caused the destruction of an entire
people and his inability to dwell on
what that image would look like compared
to lay Oreos focus on the importance of
a single person the moments so different
give me a solid indication that actually
car Ibaka is more money driven than lay
Oreo what it also highlights is the idea
that neither person would be trying to
be a hunter if something else hadn't
driven them to it which is a huge huge
counterpoint to Kilwa who is simply
bored and gone like in his excitement to
get involved in activities it looks like
we have a new main character quinoa got
a lot of screen time this episode and
since he's in the opening credits I can
only assume that he is important in some
way to the remainder of the story he and
gone are rivals they begin as rivals I
wonder if they will end as rivals
they've been perfectly placed as
opposites the ash Ketcham and Gary oak
of this universe they both have magical
tools the magical fishing rod and the
magical state that map they both have
magical tools the magical fishing rod in
the magical skateboard that requires
only one push these two are so weird
that even our mustachioed hunter subtles
looks at them like they are weird
because they are it remains to be seen
what happens when quinoa doesn't get
what he wants at the moment he's bored
which isn't very conducive to a deep
story so I'm somewhat excited to see
what happens when he gets what he wants
or realizes that to get what he wants he
has to go through someone else given the
reasons for everyone else to be at the
exam quinoa is an interesting choice
though not unexpected I haven't much
discussed the story itself in my review
of this episode and there's good reason
for that I felt the story this episode
was actually a little predictable once
the basics were put in place the second
subtle said the monsters in the
environment would try to deceive I
expected every other moment that
followed the way in which it happened
was great and I didn't expect the method
that they would use to figure things out
but I expected to have a towel I
expected that tail to be revealed by one
of the characters we've already met and
I expected Leigh audio to be wrong when
he vocally noted his fear anyway onward
to episode 5 finally someone who sees
gone for who he is and for some reason
it's not Karaka his Sokka is the
insightful creature who sees the
sociopathic gone
as the sociopath I expected and managed
to scare him in the process the sound
design of this episode was frankly
wonderful this was the first time we saw
or more specifically heard gone
experience something other than the
bland playfulness that wasn't
playfulness it was his version of
expressionless Ness instead the last
five minutes or so of the episode
included his breathing there is
something telling and breathing so I
want to dwell on that for a moment a
sound design with a focus on breathing
does a few things one it puts us into
his perspective up until now we've been
following gone as a third-person viewer
we've never literally been in gongs
shoes we've never really known what he
was thinking we just knew he had that
silly grin on his face this is the first
time I could experience him as a
character in all his empty ways in
Episode four the closeness of the sound
design and colors brought us
deliberately into Leo's life while
deliberately putting up a barrier
between us and Korra because life here
we're not behind or in front of God
we're directly in the moment with him
and that's worth a lot in it's emotional
punch to the breathing paradoxically
shifts the focus from the sound to the
visuals once you have a sense of whose
eyes you're looking through it colors
the scene we stopped caring about the
scene in any way other than the
available senses and thanks to a failing
in modern technology we can't smell
touch or taste what Gunn is smelling
touching or tasting so we're left with
what he can see we know what he can hear
his own breathing so what does he see in
this moment exactly what his soul
Cassie's a rival the true rival forget
quinoa who I secretly am not forgetting
because he said he could escape from the
Frog in Waiting but seems to have saved
gone that's for later Kilowog has too
much about gone to be a true rival I was
wrong when I said that five minutes or
so ago I was ignorant of the future
God's true rival is his Sokka and gone
himself says it later he was afraid and
he was excited he's found a reason to
compete in this exam for himself not
because his father did it he's starting
to understand why his father didn't his
father who was a hunter at 12 also young
young father did I hear that right in a
previous episode and forget to comment
on it I think so anyway
who knows when he had time to have a
sociopathic kid in any case the lack of
sound beyond gongs breathing in this
moment takes our attention away from
other senses and places it very squarely
on the fact that he is being held up by
the throat by the only thing to ever
scare him into a new emotion and once
he's had that experience he sees the
world slightly differently we see the
world with him from a new angle and with
new perspective as an aside who is
number 301 in the exam is it his Sokka
or one of his clones why is he dressed
in green the pins in the outfit suggests
that it's the purple man with the
strange pinhead but what's the
connection that's something I'll have to
wait and find out about I keep wondering
about that guy he gets a lot of screen
time and but really hasn't said anything
so I'm he's someone I'm keeping an eye
on but hang on let's return to his
soccer for a moment because I love him I
think he's quickly becoming my favorite
because he's the only one who has
managed to surprise me so far his
insightfulness his clarity and his
simplicity are so contrasting to his
outfit that I can't help but love his
design he's the first person to actually
acknowledge that God is using a fishing
rod as a method of attack and that it
may be worth taking a look at this
strange creatures weapon is Hisoka
actually already a hunter sent in to
split the chaff from the wheat its Asoka
actually Gon's father in disguise I mean
his hair is very much standing on end
who knows he's an enigma of the exciting
kind and I can't wait to see the
showdown he has with gone and possibly
kill Wow
I can imagine he and kill Wow coming to
blows at some point since there's such
different people with incredible insight
and instincts at least from kilowatts a
Hisoka Oh his soul cos music I know
music but I'm not a music theorist so
please excuse my gross assumption he's
his music the flamenco because if so
it's such a beautiful giveaway to the
fiery intensity he's actually feeling
despite his calm exterior the flamenco
is so well known for being passionate
emotionally intense and full of pride
for the movement the strength of the
music is incredible and that being his
theme is wonderful especially since it's
not just the actual music it's evocative
of the dance which is so pronounced as a
held physical style the expression that
emanates from Hisoka is a joy to watch
and I think his musical fame blends very
well with the expressive art and
of cards which are simple props with
such delicate handling needs that become
so brutal and the connection between
flamenco the clapping of hands and then
the focus of frames on his fingers
holding cards and which brings me to the
world this is the first time the world
has had what I'd say is a somewhat
direct impact on the characters though
even having said that I do wonder
whether that's the case since neither
the Frog nor the fog nor the animals
involved did actually have that much of
an impact on our mains their concerns
largely came from the other characters
it was nice to see elements of the world
and it wasn't as bland as it has been in
previous episodes there are summer
animes and mangas that exist where I
would argue the world is another
character rather than a backdrop hunter
hunter is not one of them and I'm unsure
at this point whether it's really trying
to be I'll keep an eye on that because I
do wonder whether it is a failed attempt
or a deliberate decision not to develop
the world to push the characters even
further into the foreground we'll see as
we progress I suppose but for now that's
all from me if you enjoyed this video
and the content this channel produces in
general please do consider donating to
the new world revue patreon because
there's support that math and say there
mr. sport if patreon isn't quite your
style then please do leave this video a
like share or subscribe because it also
helps support this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
and please do head over to the discord
server where a wide array of shenanigan
retakes place on a daily basis and
finally please do comment with your
thoughts on episode 4 and 5 of Hunter
hunter this has been the new world
review and I'll see you next time
you
[Music]